sehr geehrte damen und herren die lage
ist weiterhin ernst
die intensivstationen sind voll ärztin
und pflegekräfte am absoluten limit
immer mehr junge menschen erleiden
schwere verläufe deshalb wir als grüne
fraktion haben bereits bei der
einbringung klargemacht wir brauchen
einen wirksamen schnell wirksam
wellenbrecher und der ist zwingend
erforderlich und brinkhaus er stolz ich
habe eben sehr gut zugehört
es ist in der tat so wir brauchen
klarheit wir brauchen konsequenz aber
sie tragen die verantwortung dafür dass
sie allzu lange zugeschaut haben dass
wir zu spät zu zögerlich zu
widersprüchlich gehandelt haben und die
konsequenz dessen was wir jetzt erleben
ist resultat dieses nicht handeln und
ganz besonders bezeichnet ist das sieht
auch jetzt wieder den bereich der
arbeitswelt der so wichtig ist für
kontakt beschränkungen ausgelassen haben
das im übrigen hat auch die fdp wieder
in ausdrücklicher weise getan und er
froh dass es endlich dazu kommt dass der
bund die verantwortung wahrnimmt
das finden wir richtig das fordern wir
schon sehr lange wir haben deshalb auch
durchaus gerungen gestern in der
fraktion denn ein weiter so darf es
nicht geben dieses fahren auf sicht war
verantwortungslos und ist weiterhin
verantwortungslos wenn wir nicht jetzt
klar und konsequent handeln denn
es läuft sehr sehr viele menschen an der
handlungsfähigkeit unseres staates
zweifel
gleichwohl müssen wir nach diesem
herausfordernden beratungsverfahren
sagen wir können am ende diesem
infektionsschutzgesetz dieser notbremse
so nicht zustimmen denn sie handeln zu
spät zu unwirksam und sie handel
weiterhin so dass wir nicht das tun was
wir jetzt tun müssen wir anerkennen dass
es ihr mal im verlauf der beratung und
verhandlung durchaus verbesserungen
gegeben hat für die arbeitswelt beim
home office für die schule auch dabei
der präsenzpflicht und auch bei dem
bereich der ausgangs beschränkt aber
insgesamt reichen diese maßnahmen nicht
aus um tatsächlich eine trendumkehr hin
zu bekommen und genau die würden wir
brauchen zusätzlich ist dieses gesetz
handwerklich schlecht gemacht es ist in
sich inkonsequent und dem konsistent wie
sehen wir haben eine 35er instanzen
hunderter von incidents 965 er incidents
und 150 er ins ident das versteht kein
mensch und das ist auch wissenschaftlich
nicht hergeleitet deshalb diese
notbremse bleibt zu halbherzig zu wenig
wirksam zu wenig konsistent zu wenig
verhältnismäßig und deshalb können wir
an dieser stelle nicht zu stellen zu
stimmen sondern wir erwarten eine
weitere weitere
gesetzgebung damit wir hinkommen zu
echten maßnahmen die wirksam sind